[Music]
Donald Glover and the cast of Atlanta
steppin out in LA for their season 2
premiere season is here yeah one of the
inspirations for this season was my
favorite movie Tiny Toons how I spent my
summer vacation is that one of your
favorite movies isn't it the best it's
really great just a cartoon and we
watched a lot when we were kids me and
my brother we just liked how all the
stories tied into each other and now it
was like you know a cohesive piece but
it was also individualized so all the
characters on there different yeah you
and your brother got a special thanks in
the Black Panther credits and I know
that you kind of read an early draft of
the script is that correct yeah
Ryan was like racism enough to be like
uh would you take a look at the script
which was really cool and then me and
Steven you know Marvel locks things down
so he had like not as much time as I
would want to do we had a couple of
hours to look over it punch up some
jokes and do stuff like that it was
already there anyway they had already
done a great job so it was really cool
it just stood like you know get get our
fingerprints on there final question I
gotta ask you because I'm rocking this
right now I am so excited for soloist
our story especially for Lando oh my god
the costumes that you're aware and the
clothing is so bright and colorful and
awesome how is so low like totally
different from other Star Wars movies I
think it's just a lot more wine now
we're in trouble there for a second but
it's fun we're fine
now all the Star Wars is a really fun
but I think this movie we know all we
know what's gonna happen we know they're
not gonna die like it's it's pretty we
know kind of what would happen but how
we got there is I guess the the crux of
it so we're allowed to have a lot more
fun
I think and the other movies where you
have to like deal with a lot of lineage
and what's going to happen so I think
this movie is like just a fun a fun
summer film like I'm really excited
about it's really cool I cannot wait